we call another one like it you know I
think it's an 85 like when all that and
rising it was going on and what was wild
was that the guy who looked the most
like like a bitch was getting all the
women you and I had a jheri curl was
coming out and I had my six inside and
all that if you went back
now I'm yakking hard if you from LA you
meup was when I came here in the club we
get jug room or shake it up and Prince
came in that's when Purple Rain came out
and Prince was the you know I'm saying
Prince had one leg up it was like a
Zorro type outfit had two ruffles would
come down in the front we had the big
turn struck down mustache everything
that was drawing on his face it looks
like it's something that a figure
skating we're no Sam
and he's with his whole crew and he had
this other cat named Mickey free and
Mickey free was like the new cat and
Shalimar that when he joined a group I
heard man cats like yo Sean Moore got me
new girl in there met bits for our like
the more we talk about Mickey Street
okay Mickey free is not a girl all right
they came over where we was at
Prince I talked to my brother hello
Eddie Murphy a big fan of your comedies
would you like to come to my house and
listen to some music oh that's cold
fruity get the car assemble your crew on
the outside we went up here we get they
put some tracks on tracks of slammin you
know I mean listening to the music and
groovin at the cribs that get girls over
there
yeah nice environment it was it was
tight this bores me there's anyone up
for a game of basketball how about you
and your friends versus me and the
revolution
so I was it must be joking man the way
to go this he was dead serious
he had his uh help or whatever go and
get some like shorts and sneakers and
gave them to us and laughing I'm like
this is gonna be funny so they come out
right and I look at them you know they
still got on the same they be wearing at
the club
it was wild I was like I know they
anything about playing ball in that but
they were say hey you know what
yo we gonna call this the shirts against
the blouse and when I said that this
look came on his face and I'm looking
back in him thinking to myself you know
what are you angry about I mean you know
what you got that shirt for damn sure
wasn't the men's department I mean I
kind of learned something that they
don't then that would judge a book by
its cover this cat could ball me play
ball he was crossing cat-like
name I need slam together he was getting
rebounds like Charles Barkley smashing
exam CJ trying to play computer blue
darling pinky day was kind of setting
these fruity pics man you don't saying
that you were trying to check prints and
then you got this cat standing behind
you and he's getting close to you in his
hands is out like this you don't really
want to be bent over when I can't like
dad no Sam
prince is incredible great we've got a
towel man it's kind of hot out here me
why don't you purify yourself in the
waters of Lake Minnetonka good and your
face Charlie Murphy good good hustle yo
I'm not on your team
I mean it wasn't even like it was close
it was a landslide victory game blouses
yeah I see you don't believe me you
think I'm making it up you think I'm
trying to how to give myself the excuse
for losing cause I'm telling you a story
about print I dare you the challenge
prints to the game ball one-on-one
challenge you all right and that makes
sure your people is there to see the
game cuz you might get embarrassed
trust me all right he beat some
basketball and then what happened after
it was all over he took us in the house
of service pancake
thank you well I gotta admit them it's a
good game I wish I could say the same
for you and three flunkies do you guys
want some grapes I mean you know there's
some great storytellers in the world we
live in today man bitches
you
[Applause]
we gonna hang out with Rick James than
that you know I'm saying and he comes
out the room when I look at him and I'm
not bullshitting math seem like like an
orange his order or whatever I see
[Music]
and started taping me and he was mad
bitch man which was right up my alley
I'm on the baddest mother cuz of all
time one of the best thing is one of the
best-looking mother you've ever seen
hold my drink bitch you go over to any
chick lit the whole Saturday face man
[Music]
I'm Rick James bitch enjoy yourself you
got closer started hanging out my
brother didn't do anything so at night
when Eddie would break out we would all
be doing it getting crazy and wild if I
was hanging with Rick he had to sting
with me where he used to always like
with me man I don't I don't know what
what started it but you know he was
hanging out with the big dogs you know
you know Charlie didn't know he was
doing crazy things and I had to
straighten him out sometimes out of go
upside his head things escalated to the
point where you know my man got too
familiar and I ended up having the whip
his ass man no because you know he step
across the line habitually he's a
habitual line step one first time you
know I had end up whipping his ass we
went to studio 54 we walking up into the
VIP section you know I'm looking around
and see who's damn girls they think and
all of a sudden I heard something my
back
[Applause]
she had this ring or commemorate this
song he had put out call unity and this
was a distance and this was imprinted in
that black head of his for at least a
week that was the funniest and so
that weird space cuz I'm like yeah this
is Rick James he's a star maybe I'm
overreacting with you like maybe I
shouldn't do nothing but my ghetto sad
was going yo stop this mother guy right
here gets wrong with him oh I'm dead
steel one no I'm saying what are you
gonna smack me back I'm Rick James he's
Charlie Murphy I waited cuz I knew what
hotel he was standing Eddie you know
went home and I said gotta be right back
i shat over to the hotel went up to his
room knocked on the door so then he
comes in there and I said look bitch I'm
Rick Jane he had his hand cut to throw
another red hand
what he's coming for his camp quarter
would be front hoop teller like he gave
me so got a Bruce Lee cross kick or
something I kicked it out
[Applause]
when his knocked out and then he screams
out Sakana the one in the front
he had crooked eyes and she was one I
was looking at me the other one was
looking at Rick Rick head and she's over
by the window now darkness the tables
are turned
do with him whatever you like mother
let's take one more step I'm kicking his
at the with fries you know
you was wrong what you did to me earlier
look what you did in my face
I'm sorry telomere if it was an accident
I was having too much fun our fewer
troops the stickiest of the ickey you
want to smoke with the old boy Rick
James yo man my forehead is bumping me
now that you mention it I think I'm
bleeding inside my chest but I got the
medicine bitch : have sex with Charlie
Murphy I'm Rick James bitch
that was her that particular incident in
you but it wasn't the last time I had to
represent a represent what possess don't
you think sighs a little old of you
taking karate you probably check it with
the little kids dreams I told you
Charlie has delusions of grandeur in the
studio 54 thing you know that that blew
over I'm saying no but then you know
here we go again
cocaine's a hell of a drug Ricky's
encouraging
shows up and my brother's house nice
place so he had dirty cowboy boots let's
push this out of the way barged in the
house
my brother had these brand new couches
they were suede right and he gets on the
couch this is why don't I stretch out
and just study crying mud on my feet
cause my complexion needs to call me
darkness he calls me and my brother
Duncan saw the darkness brothers this is
long before Wesley Snipes back then we
use the black
twin brother doctors now we stand in
look he's with the right in our eyes as
his granny's mud things just to do them
she's almost let just jump up and grind
my feet on somebody's couch like it's
like a shield something to do come on I
got a little more sense than that
yeah I know my feeling at his help just
did things just to do them come on she's
also just jump up and grind my penis
somebody's couch like it's like it's you
know something to do come on I had a
little more sense than that
yeah bummer drama then it was like no
way there's one over there
well blaze you were cold as ice but
still Rick James
you would have to take in a beating like
that yo cops this is going
out his legs is like like been green
[Laughter]
brother you know he's a he's a lot more
compassionate than I am he's looking at
let most dry rot we said wow man Rick
really needs help house thanks yo we
just gave him some help
rusty yeah I bet you he won't come over
here disrespect like that again
wrong wrong talk James cocaine is a hell
of a drug
[Music]